We've begun gone the turn to Plato's dialogue of Thedo and what I started doing
last time was sketching the basic outlines of Plato's metaphysics.
Not so much to give a full investigation of that.
Clearly we're not going to do that here,
but just to provide enough of the essential outlines of Plato's metaphysical
views so that we can understand the arguments that come up later in the fito
basically all of which are many of which presuppose something certain essential
aspects about Plato's metaphysical views.
The key point behind his metaphysics then was the,
was the thought that in addition to the ordinary empirical physical world that
we're all familiar with,
we have to posit the existence of a kind of second realm,
uh,
in which exist the platonic as their nowadays called the platonic forms or
platonic ideas sort of thing that perhaps we might call or think of as abstract
objects or abstract properties.
And the,
and the reason for positing these things is because we're clearly able to think
about these ideas and yet we recognize that the ordinary physical world,
although things may participate in them to varying degrees,
we don't actually come across these objects or entities in the physical world so
that we can talk about things being beautiful to varying degrees,
but we never come across beauty itself in the actual empirical world.
We,
we are able to talk about the fact that two plus one equals three but it's not
as though we ever come across numbers number three itself,
anywhere in the empirical world.
Further point to that distinguishes the empirical world from this sort of this
realm of platonic ideal objects is that indeed the,
there's,
there's something perfect about them.
They don't change.
And in contrast,
physical objects are constantly changing.
Something might be short at one point and become tall at another point.
Ugly at one point it become beautiful.
Like,
like the ugly duckling.
It starts out ugly becomes a Beautiful Swan and contrast.
Justice itself never changes.
Beauty itself never changes.
We have the thought that these things are eternal.
And,
and,
and indeed the beyond change and in contrast to the empirical world,
in fact,
if you start thinking more about the world from this perspective,
the,
the world we live in is crazy.
It's almost insanely contradictory.
Plato thinks of it as,
as,
as crazy in the way that a dream is when you're,
when you're caught up in the dream,
you don't notice just how insane it all is.
But if you start to step back and reflect on it,
oh,
let's see.
I was eating a sandwich and suddenly the sandwich was the statue of liberty,
except the statue of Liberty was my mother.
And she's flying over the ocean,
except she's really a piece of spaghetti.
But that's how dreams are.
And when you're in it,
it sort of all makes sense.
Right?
UK caught up,
but yet a step back and say,
that's just insane.
Well,
Plato thinks that the empirical world has something of that kind of insanity.
Something of that kind of contradictory Enos built into it that we don't
ordinarily notice.
Uh,
he,
he's a basketball player,
so he's really,
really tall,
except he's only a six feet.
So he's really,
really short.
Uh,
for a basketball player,
you know,
this is a baby elephant,
so it's really,
really big except it's a baby elephant.
So it's really,
really small.
The world is constantly sort of rolling.
This is a platonic expression rolling between sort of one form and the other
and,
and it's hard to make sense of.
In contrast,
the mind is able to grasp the platonic ideas,
the platonic forms,
and they're stable,
they're reliable,
they are there,
they're law like,
and we can,
we can grasp them.
They don't change their eternal that,
as I say,
the platonic picture now,
it's not my purpose here to try to argue for or against Platonism with regard to
abstract entities.
As I suggested and talking about the example of math last time,
it's not a silly view,
even if it's not a view that we all take automatically.
But in thinking about math,
most of us are inclined to be politeness.
We all do believe something makes it true.
The two plus one equals three but it's not the fact that empirical objects w we
don't do empirical experiments to see whether two plus one equals three rather
we think our mind can grasp the trues about numbers.
Plato thought everything was like that.
Well,
I'm not going to argue for and against that.
If you just wanted to sketch it for the so as to understand the arguments that
turn on it.
So for our purposes,
let's suppose Plato was right about that and ask what follows or Plato thinks.
What's going to follow is we have some reason to believe in the immortality of
the soul as again he was.
We indicated last time that the picture is that the mind,
the soul is able to grasp these eternal platonic forms.
The ideas.
Typically we're distracted from thinking about them by the,
by the distractions provided by the body,
the desire for food,
drink,
sex,
what have you,
sleep.
But by distancing itself from the body,
the mind,
the soul is able to better concentrate on the forms.
And if you're good at that,
if you practice while you're alive,
separating yourself from the body,
then when your body dies,
the mind is able to go up to this platonic realm and commune with,
with Gods and other immortal souls and think about the forms.
But if you are not separated yourself from the body while in life,
if you're too enmeshed in its concerns,
then upon the death of your body,
your soul will get sort of sucked back in reincarnated perhaps in another body
if you're lucky,
as another person,
if you're not so lucky as a pig or a donkey or an aunt or what have you.
So your goal,
Plato says your goal should be in life to practice death,
to separate yourself from your body.
And because of this Socrates who's facing death isn't distressed at the
prospect,
but,
but happy he's,
he's happy that the final separation will take place and he'll be able to go to
heaven.
Okay.
The dialogue ends of course with the death scene,
Socrates has been condemned to death by the Athenians,
uhh,
and it ends with his drinking,
the hemlock knocked distressed but rather sort of joyful.
Uh,
and the dialogue ends with one of the great moving death scenes in western
civilization.
And as,
as Plato says,
let's get the quote here.
Exactly right.
Of all those we have known he was the best and also the wisest and the most
upright
just before the death scene.
There's a long myth,
which I draw your attention to,
but I don't want to discuss in any kind of detail.
Plato says it's a story,
it's a myth.
He's trying to indicate that there are things that we can't really know in a,
in a scientific way,
but we can,
we can glimpse.
Yeah.
And and the myth has to do with these sort of pictures I was just describing
where we don't actually live on the surface of the earth,
sort of in the light but rather live in certain hollows in the dark where were
mistaken about the nature of reality.
Some of you who are maybe familiar with Plato's later dialogue,
the republic may recognize at least what seems to me what we have here is a a
foreshadowing of the,
the myth of the cave or the allegory of the cave which Plato describes there as
well.
Yeah.
Our concern is going to be the arguments that make up the center of the dialogue
because in the center of the dialogue before he dies,
Socrates is arguing with his friends.
Socrates just say,
look,
I'm not worried,
I'm going to live forever.
And His disciples and friends are worried whether this is true or not.
And so the,
the heart of the dialogue consists of a series of arguments that in which
Socrates attempt to lay out his reasons for believing in the immortality of the
soul and that's going to be our concern,
but I'm going to do is basically run through my attempt to reconstruct my
attempt to lay out the basic ideas from this series of four or five arguments
that Plato gives us.
I'm going to criticize them.
I don't think they work though.
I wanted a remark before I turn to them that insane.
This,
I'm not necessarily criticizing Plato as we'll see.
Some of the later arguments seem to be deliberately emailed at answering
objections that we can raise to some of the earlier arguments and so it might
well be that Plato himself recognized that the initial arguments aren't as
strong as they need to be.
Plato wrote the dialogues as a kind of learning device as a tool to help the
reader get better at doing philosophy there.
They don't necessarily represent in a kind of systematic fashion.
Plato's worked out axiomatic views about the nature of philosophy.
It couldn't.
It could be that Plato's deliberately putting mistakes in earlier arguments so
as to encourage you to think for yourself,
oh,
this is the,
here's a problem with this argument.
Here's an objection with that argument.
Some of these Plato then may address later on.
But whether or not he doesn't dress them,
we're not doing Plato any honor.
We're not doing them any service.
If we limit ourselves to simply trying to grasp,
here's what Plato thought,
we could do the history of ideas and say,
here's Plato's views.
Aren't they interesting?
Notice how they differ from Aristotle's views.
And move on like that.
But that's not what the philosophers wanted us to do.
The full,
the great philosophers had arguments that they were putting forward to try to
persuade us of the truth of their positions.
And the way you show respect for a philosopher is by taking those arguments
seriously and asking yourself,
do they work or not?
So whether or not the views that are being put forward in Socrates,
his mouth are the considered reflective judgments of Plato or not.
For our purposes.
We can just act as though they were the arguments being put forward by Plato and
we can ask ourselves do these arguments work or don't think so.
I'm going to run through a series of these arguments.
I'm going to,
as I've mentioned before,
be a bit more exegetical than is normally the case where our readings,
I'm going to actually pause periodically look at my notes and make sure I'm
remembering how I think Plato understands the arguments.
Of course since the dialogue is indeed a dialogue,
we don't always have the arguments laid out with a series of premises
conclusions and so it's always a matter of interpretation.
What's the best reconstruction of the argument.
He's gesturing towards how can we turn it into an argument with premises and
conclusions,
but that's what I'm going to try to do for us.
Also going to give the argument names.
These are not names that Plato gives,
but it'll make it easy for us to get a fix roughly on the different arguments as
we moved from one to the next.
So the first argument and the worry that it gets the whole thing going is this.
So we've got this nice platonic picture where Plato says,
all right,
so the mind can grasp the eternal forms,
but that has to free itself from the body to do that.
And so the philosopher who has sort of trained himself to separate his mind from
his body,
did it disregard his bodily a cravings and desires?
The philosopher will welcome death because at that point he'll truly finally
make the final break from the body.
And the army's worry that gets raised in the dialogue at this point is this,
how do we know that when the death of the body occurs,
the soul doesn't get destroyed as well.
That's the natural worry to have.
You know,
maybe what we need to do is separate ourselves as much as possible from the
influence of our body without actually going all the way and breaking the
connection.
If you think of it like a rubber band,
maybe the more we can stretch the rubber band,
the better.
But if you stretch too far and the rubber band snaps,
that's not good.
That's bad.
It couldn't be that we need the body in order to continue thinking.
We want to free ourselves from the distractions of the body,
but we don't want the body to die because when the body dies,
the soul dies as well.
Even if we are dualists,
as we've noticed before,
even if the soul is something different from the body,
it could still be the case logically speaking,
that if the body gets destroyed,
the soil gets destroyed as well.
And so Socrates friends ask him,
how can we be confident that the soul will survive the death of the body and
indeed be a mortal?
And that's what prompts the series of arguments.
Now,
the first such argument,
I dub the argument from the nature of the forms.
Okay.
And the basic thoughts fairly straight forward.
The ideas or the forms?
Justice itself,
beauty itself.
Goodness itself.
The forms are not physical objects,
right?
We don't,
we don't ever bump into justice itself.
We bumped into societies that may be more or less just or individuals who may be
more or less just,
but we never bump into justice itself.
The number three is not a physical object.
Goodness itself is not a physical object.
Perfect roundness is not a physical object.
Now,
roughly speaking,
soccer seems to think it's going to follow straight forwardly from that,
that the soul must itself be something nonphysical.
If if the
forms are not physical objects,
then Socrates thinks it follows.
They can't be grasped.
We can certainly think about the forms,
but if they're not physical,
they can't be grasped by something physical like the body.
They've got to be grasped by something nonphysical,
namely the soul.
But although that's I think the,
the sketch of where Socrates wants to go,
it doesn't quite give us what we want.
On the one hand,
even if it was true that the soul must be nonphysical in order to grasp the
nonphysical forms,
wouldn't follow that.
The soul will survive the death of the body.
That's the problem we've been thinking about for the last minute.
And there's something puzzling we might wonder.
Well,
just why is it that the body can't grasp the forms?
So there's a sort of fuller version of the argument.
That's the one I want to focus on.
And indeed,
I've put it up on the board.
So platonic metaphysics gives us premise number one,
that ideas forms are eternal and their nonphysical
okay
to that which is eternal or nonphysical can only be grasped by the eternal and
the nonphysical.
Suppose we had both of those.
It would seem to give us three.
That conclusion.
We want that which grasps the ideas or the forms must be eternal or nonphysical.
Okay.
What is it?
The grass,
the ideas or the forms?
Well,
that's the soul.
If that was grasped,
the idea is a forms must be 29 physical.
Well,
one thing we're going to get is since that was grasps the,
the forms must be nonphysical.
The is not the body.
Since that was grasp,
the idea of forms must be eternal or nonphysical.
It's eternal.
It's not.
It's immortal.
All right,
let's look at us again more carefully.
Ideas or forms are eternal.
They're nonphysical.
Well,
I've emphasized the nonphysical aspect and I've emphasized as well if they're
not changing,
but perhaps it's worth taking a moment to emphasize the eternal aspect of the
forms.
People may come and go,
but perfect justice.
You know the idea of perfect justice that's timeless.
Nothing that happens here on earth can change or alter or destroy.
The number three,
two plus one equals three.
Before there were people,
Now two plus one will always equal three.
The number three is eternal as well as being nonphysical.
So the platonic metaphysics says quite generally,
if we're thinking about the ideas or the forms,
the point to grasp is they're eternal.
There.
Nonphysical.
The crucial premise since we're getting Plato,
number one,
the crucial premise for our purposes is premise number two.
Is it or isn't it true that those things which are eternal or nonphysical can
only be grasped by something that is itself eternal and nonphysical?
Again,
it does seem as though the conclusion that he wants.
Number three follows from that.
If we give him number two,
it's going to file that whatever is doing the grasping call that the soul,
since the soul is just Plato's word for our mind,
if whatever's doing,
the grasping of the eternal nonphysical forms must itself be eternal and
nonphysical.
It follows that the soul must be nonphysical.
So the physical,
his view is wrong and the soul must be eternal.
The soles are mortal.
So Socrates has what he wants once we get him.
Premise number two,
that the eternal nonphysical can only be grasped by the eternal nonphysical
as
Socrates puts it at one point,
the impure cannot attain the pure bodies corruptible destroyable physical,
you know,
passing whether they exist or not exist for a brief period than they ceased to
exist.
They sort of impure objects cannot attain,
cannot grasp,
can not have knowledge of the eternal changeless nonphysical forms.
The impure cannot attain the pure.
That's the crucial premise and what I want to say is as far as I can see,
there's no good reason to believe number two.
Now number two is not an unfamiliar premise.
Number two is not an unfamiliar claim.
I take it.
The claim basically is that it has to put it in more familiar language.
It takes one to know one
or to use it.
Some other kinds of language of Plato users at various points.
You know,
like so known by likes,
but it takes one to know.
One is probably the most familiar way of putting the point.
Plato saying,
what is it that we know what we know?
The eternal forms takes one to know one.
So we must ourselves be terminal.
Unfortunately,
this thought populars that may be that it takes one to know one just seems
false.
Think about some examples.
Well,
let's see.
Uh,
I buy all just might study or a zoologist might study cats.
takes one to know one.
So the biologist must himself be a cat.
Well,
that's clearly false.
You don't have to be feline to study.
The feline
takes one to know one.
So,
uh,
you can't be a Canadian and study Mexicans because it takes one to know one.
Well,
that's just clearly stupid.
Of course,
the Canadians can study the Mexicans and the Germans can study.
The French does not take one to know one.
To understand the truth about the French.
You do not yourself need to be French or take the fact that some doctors study,
you know,
dead bodies.
Huh?
So to study and grasp things about dead bodies,
corpses,
you must yourself be a dead body.
No,
that certainly doesn't follow.
So if we start actually pushing ourselves to think about example,
does it really take one to know one?
The answer is at least as a general claim,
it's not true.
It doesn't normally take one to know one.
No.
Strictly speaking,
that doesn't prove that premise two is false.
It could still be that,
although normally you don't have to be like the thing that you're studying in
order to study it.
Although that's not normally true.
It could be that in the particular case of nonphysical objects in the particular
case of eternal objects,
you do have to be eternal nonphysical to study them.
It could be that even though the general claim it takes one to know one is
false,
that particular claim eternal nonphysical can only be grasped by the eternal
nonphysical.
Maybe that particular claim is true and it's only the particular claim that
Plato needs.
Still,
all I can say is why shouldn't we believe too?
Why should we think there's some,
you know,
even though normally the the,
the barrier can be crossed and exes can study the Nanex,
why should that bear?
You're suddenly uncrossable in the particular instance when we're dealing with
platonic forms give us some reason to believe premise too.
I can't see any good reason to believe premise too and as far as I can see,
Plato doesn't actually give us any reason to believe it in the dialogue.
Consequently,
we have to say as far as I can see,
we haven't been given any adequate argument by the conclusion that the soul
which admittedly can think about forms and ideas,
we have no good reason yet to believe to be persuaded that the soul must itself
be eternal and nonphysical.
That's the first argument.
As I say though,
Plato may well recognize the inadequacy of that argument because after all
Socrates goes on to offer a series of other arguments.
So let's turn to the next.
I call the second argument.
The argument from recycling.
It's not the best label I suppose,
but I've never been able to come up with a better one.
And the basic idea is,
well that parts get reused,
things move from one state to another state and then back to the first state.
So for example,
to give an example of that player actually gives him the dialogue.
You know,
we are all awake now,
but previously we were asleep.
We went from being in the realm of the asleep to being in the realm of the awake
and we're going to return from the realm of the awake back to the realm of the
asleep and over and over and over again.
Hence recycling.
I think I'm actually a better example for Plato's purposes.
Not that I expected to have this particular example,
but would be a car.
Cars are made up of parts that existed before the car itself existed.
No,
there was the engine and the steering wheel and the tires and so forth.
And these parts got assembled and put together to make up a car.
So the parts of the car existed prior to the existence of the car itself.
And the time's going to come when the car will cease to exist,
but it's parts will still be around and it'll get taken apart for parts sold for
parts,
you know,
there'll be the distributor cap and there'll be the tires and they're all way
the carburetor there.
I mean the steering wheel,
hence the uh,
the name like dub,
the argument,
the argument from recycling.
That's the nature of sort of reality for things.
And it seems like a plausible enough view.
Things come into being by being composed of previously existing parts.
And then when those things cease to have the form they had,
the parts get used for other purposes,
they get recycled.
If we grant that to Plato,
he thinks we've got an argument for the immortality of the soul.
Because after all,
what are the parts that make us up?
Well,
it was the various parts of our physical body,
but there's also our soul.
I remember,
as I said,
in introducing the Fito,
Plato doesn't so much argue for the existence of something separate the soul as
presuppose it his,
his fundamental concern is to try to argue for the immortality of the soul,
so he's just helping himself to the assumption that there is a soul.
It's one of the parts that makes us,
makes that goes up.
It did.
Making this up,
it goes into making this up.
One of the pieces that constitutes us given the thesis about recycling.
Then we have reasonable leave.
The soul will continue to exist after sort of,
we break even after our deaths are parts will continue to exist.
You know,
our body continues to exist even after our death.
Our soul will continue to exist.
Well,
there's a problem with the argument from recycling and it's this,
even if the recycling thesis shows us that we're made up of something that
existed before our birth
and that some kinds of parts are going to have to exist after our death,
we can't conclude that the soul is one of the parts that's going to continue to
exist after our death.
Consider some familiar facts about human bodies.
We as we nowadays,
no human bodies are made up of atoms and it's certainly true that the atoms that
make up my body existed long before my body existed,
and it's certainly true that after my death,
those atoms are going to continue to exist.
So there's some and we'll eventually get used to make something else.
So Plato certainly right about recycling as a fundamental truth.
The things that make me up existed before and will continue to exist after my
death.
But that doesn't mean that every part of my body existed before I was born and
that every part of my body will continue to exist after I die.
Take my heart.
My heart is a part of my body.
Yet for all that it didn't exist before my body began to exist.
It came into existence as part of a long with the creation of my body
and it won't continue to exist,
at least not very long after the destruction of my body.
There'll be a brief period in which as a cadaver,
I suppose my heart will continue to exist but eventually my body will decompose.
We certainly wouldn't have any grounds to conclude my heart is immortal will
exist forever.
That just seems wrong.
So even though it's true that some kind of recycling takes place,
we can't conclude that everything that's now a part of me will continue to exist
afterwards cause it might not have been one of the parts,
one of the fundamental parts from which I'm built,
like the heart
and if that's right,
if there can be parts that I have now that more one of the parts from which I
was made,
there's no particular reason to think it's going to be one of the parts.
It's going to continue to exist after I die.
Once we see that kind of worry,
we have to see,
look,
same thing could be true for the soul.
Even if there is an immortal soul,
sorry.
Even if there is a nonphysical soul,
that's part of me.
We don't yet have any reason to believe that it's one of the fundamental
building blocks that were being recycled.
We don't have adequate reason to conclude that it's something that existed
before I was put together.
It's something that will be recycled and continue to exist after I fall apart
after my body.
You know,
decomposers after I'm separated from my body,
what have you.
Even if recycling takes place,
we don't have any good reason yet to believe that the soul is one of the
recycled parts,
so it seems to me the argument from recycling as I call it is not successful
either.
Okay.
No.
As I say,
many times when you read the dialogue this or other dialogues by Plato,
it seems as though he's fully cognizant of the objections that at least an
attentive reader will raise about earlier stages of the argument because
sometimes the best way to understand a later argument is to see it as responding
to the weaknesses of earlier arguments and I think that's pretty clearly what's
going on in the very next argument that comes up in the dialogue.
What the objection I just raised after all to the argument from recycling said
in effect,
even though some kind of recycling takes place,
not all my parts get recycled because not all of my parts were among the
preexisting constituent pieces from which I'm built up.
We don't have any particular reason to take my heart's one of the premier prior
existing pieces.
We don't have any good reason to assume that my soul is one of the prior
Well,
Plato's very next argument attempts to persuade us that indeed we do have reason
to believe that the soul is one of the prior existing pieces
and this argument
is known as the argument from recollection.
The idea is he's going to tell us certain facts that need explaining and the
best explanation involves a certain fact about recollecting or certain claim
about recollecting or remembering,
but we can only remember he thinks in the relevant way if our soul existed
before the birth of our body,
before the creation of our body.
All right.
What's the,
what's the,
what's the crucial fact?
Well,
let's,
let's start by.
Plato starts by telling us,
reminding us of what it is to remember something,
or perhaps a better word would be what it is to be reminded of something by
something else.
Okay?
That resembles it,
but it's not the thing.
It reminds you of,
I might have a photograph of my friend Ruth
and looking at the photograph reminds me of Ruth.
It brings Ruth to mind.
I start thinking about Ruth.
I remember various things I know about Ruth.
The photographs is,
is able to do that,
is able to trigger these thoughts,
but of course the photograph is not Ruth,
right?
Nobody would,
who's thinking clearly would confuse that photograph with my friend,
but the photograph resembles Ruth.
It resembles Ruth well enough to remind me of her,
and interestingly it do that.
Even if it's not a very good photograph.
It might hold up the photograph and I might say,
gosh,
that really doesn't look very much like Ruth does it.
Even though I see that it is a photograph of Ruth,
it reminds me of her.
Now how could it be that a photograph reminds me of my friend?
Oh,
this is some deep mystery.
Presumably the way it works is,
as I just said,
it looks sort of like her.
It doesn't have to look very much like here it looks sort of like her,
you know,
you're your young brother or sister.
My little children can draw
pictures of family members that barely look like family members.
My,
my,
my niece drew a picture of my family once when she was here.
Three,
it didn't look very much like us at all.
But we can sort of see the resemblance in a vague kind of way.
Right?
So
it's got to look at least somewhat like the missing friend.
But that's not enough.
You've never met Ruth.
Let's suppose I hold up the photograph without having told you anything about
her photographs.
Knock on to remind you of Ruth.
Why not?
Well,
you don't know Ruth.
So the pieces we need are not only an image of Ruth,
even if an imperfect image of Ruth,
we also need some prior acquaintance with Ruth.
That's pretty much what it takes,
right?
So on the one hand sort of temporal sequence.
First,
Ya Know Ruth,
you meet Ruth,
you get to know Ruth.
Then at a later time
you're shown an image of Ruth.
Maybe not even an especially good image of Ruth,
but good enough to remind you and suddenly you're remembering things you know
about Ruth.
That's how recollection works.
All right?
Now,
Plato points out that we all know things about the platonic forms.
Okay,
but the platonic forms,
as we also know are not to be found in this world.
Then number three is not a physical object.
Perfect roundness is not a physical object.
Perfect goodness is not a physical object.
We can think about these things.
Our mind can grasp them,
but they're not to be found in this world yet.
Various things that we do find in this world get us thinking about those things.
I look at the plate on my kitchen table.
It's not perfectly round.
It's got imperfections,
but suddenly I start thinking about circles,
perfectly round objects.
I look at somebody who's pretty,
he or she is not perfectly beautiful,
but suddenly I start thinking about the nature of beauty itself.
Ordinary objects in the world participate to a greater or lesser degree in the
platonic forms.
That's the,
that's played,
I was picture of metaphysics and we bump up against,
we look at,
we have interactions with these every day objects and somehow they get us
thinking about the platonic forms themselves.
How does it happen?
Plato has a theory.
He says these things remind us of the platonic forms.
We see something that's beautiful to some degree and it reminds us of perfect
beauty.
We see something that's more or less round and it reminds us of perfect
circularity.
We see somebody who's fairly decent morally and it reminds us of perfect justice
or perfect virtue.
It's just like the photograph,
perhaps the not very good photograph.
That reminds me of my friend Ruth.
Alright,
well there was an explanation of how it could be that things that are not
themselves perfectly round could remind us,
could make us think about perfect roundness,
but,
but then Plato says,
okay,
but keep in mind all what you need in order to have reminding to have
recollecting take place in order for the photograph to remind me of Ruth,
I have to all ready have met Ruth.
I have to already be acquainted with her
in order for uh,
more or less round plate to remind me of roundness.
Plato says I have to have all ready met perfect roundness itself in order for a
more or less just society to remind me of justice itself.
So that can start thinking about the nature of justice itself.
I have to somehow have already been acquainted with perfect justice,
but how and when did it happen?
Not In this life,
not in this world.
In this world.
Nothing is perfectly round.
Nothing is perfectly beautiful.
Nothing is perfectly just so it's got to have happened before.
If seeing the photograph of my friend now can remind me of my friend.
It's got to be because I met my friend before.
Okay.
If seen things that participate in the forms,
remind me of the forms.
It's got to be because I've met or been acquainted with directly with the forms
before,
but you don't bump up against,
you don't meet,
you don't see or grasp or become directly acquainted with the forms in this
life.
So it's got to have happened before this life.
That's Plato's argument.
Plato says,
thinking about the way in which we grasp the forms helps us to see that the soul
must have existed before birth in the,
in the platonic heavenly realm,
directly grasping,
directly communing with directly understanding the forms.
It's not taking place in this life.
So it has to have happened before.
Well look,
now we've got the kind of argument we were looking for earlier.
The objection was we had no good reason to think the soul was one of the
building blocks from which were composed.
We have no good reason to think.
It's one of the pieces that was around before our body got put together before
you know,
before our birth,
Socrates says no.
On the contrary,
we do have reason based on the argument from recollection to conclude at this
soul was around before we were born.
Okay.
All right,
so next question is,
is the argument from recollection a good one?
Now
Z ,
I'm not really much concerned with whether this is an argument that Plato
thought worked or not.
Our question is do we think it works or not?
Although this is a form of an argument that Plato does put forward and other
dialogues as well and so talk to me,
so there's,
there's at least some reason I think this is an argument that he thought might
well be right.
The crucial premise,
again,
we're going to just grant Plato the metaphysics.
The crucial questions going to be,
is it right that in order to explain how it is,
we could have knowledge of the forms now that we have to appeal to a prior
existence in which we had direct acquaintance.
Okay.
It's not obvious to me if that's true.
It's not obvious to me for a couple of reasons.
One,
one question is this,
is it really true that in order to think about the perfectly straight,
I must have somehow somewhere at some point come up against,
had direct knowledge of the perfectly straight?
Isn't it enough for me to extrapolate from cases that I do come up against in
this life?
I come across things that are bent,
I come across things that are more straight,
more and more straight.
Can't my mind take off from there and push straight ahead to the idea of the
perfectly straight,
even if I never have encountered it before?
Let me stop with this idea.
Even if Plato was right,
that we need to have acquaintance with the platonic forms and selves in order to
think about them,
and even if Plato was right,
that we never get the acquaintance in this world,
in the interaction with ordinary physical objects,
why couldn't it be that our acquaintance with the platonic forms comes about in
this life for the very first time?
All right.
That's the question.
That's the objection.
That will turn to it.
Start up next class.